good
morning it being 10:00 I will call the
fiscal committee The Joint fiscal
committee to order
for uh December December 15
2023 I will point out we have some
Replacements today we have Senator
Shanley joining us to replace Senator
Rosenwald Senator Ward is joining us to
replace Senator Bradley we have
representative Griffin to replace
representative
Edwards first item on the agenda is the
acceptance of the minutes of November
9th 2023 I don't entertain a motion and
Senator Murphy is here replacing oh
Senator Murphy is replacing Senator bsil
thank
you all right second is there any
additions or Corrections on the minutes
seeing none are ready for the question
all in favor to accept the minutes from
November 9th say I I oppose no minutes
are adopted next we'll go to Old
business
do we have someone here from the
Attorney General's
you whoever else you need have them come
please turn the mics on first please see
a red light and then we can hear you
better got it okay thank
you Jen Foley general counsel for the
fund
Mr chairman I'm Jennifer Ramsey with the
Attorney General's office who Jennifers
okay that's right and there are several
fund welcome thank you um let me just
lead off by saying I apologize that we
were not here last time we had a
miscommunication and we appreciate the
opportunity to present the uh report to
you today I'll let attorney Foley who
drafted the report present to you uh the
information and and then I'm happy to
answer any questions that anyone has
thank
you so the report is is meant to be
responsive to um the statute's directive
to um give a picture of the number of
claims filed the number of claims
resolved the kinds of abuse that um is
both filed as a claim and also resolved
um so if there's specific questions on
the numbers I can address that um I can
also give you a sense we're about to
close quarter 4 I can give you a sensus
to what a couple of numbers that we're
that you may be interested in at at the
close we didn't get anything in writing
so if you'd spill out the numbers a bit
okay four quarter four or four quarter
three four how many cases filed how many
have been settled okay how much money
has been U
promised and if I may since we're
presenting the quarter 3 report I think
it would be appropriate to report those
numbers sure yep
okay so uh the number and total claim
amount for filed claims the total fil
claims for quarter 3 was 180 claims
filed um there was a as a picture for
quarter 1 there was 38 claims filed um
and for quarter three to give you a
picture there was excuse me 88 claims
volume in terms of the nature of abuse
of Cl
claims um from those 180 claims there
are claims that F that allege both
sexual abuse and physical abuse 138 of
the 180 claims represent that
category some of the claims um claim Cy
sexual abuse
only 26 um is the is the number for the
180 and some of the claims allege
physical abuse only um and that is 16
and we do um
so far see a a smaller portion that are
only in terms of the pending claims in
other words the ones that have not been
resolved yet um at the close of quarter
3 148 claims out of the 180 were still
pending in the process there's a number
of steps that the claims processing
involves so it does take uh careful uh
managing and shepherding through those
steps in order to get to resolution and
there's two ways of of resolving as you
know one is through the Attorney
General's office um by way of mutual
agreement with the parties um or should
the parties uh seek a resolution
proceeding with the administrator that's
another opportunity for resolution by
decision
so from the 180 claims that were pending
at the end of quarter
3 29 of them were
resolved 28 of those 29 were resolved
through mutual agreement with the
Attorney General's office one uh was
resolved by the administrator by the
close of quarter three of course that
that number is different now that were a
three
for the settled amounts those resolved
amounts 13 milon
390,000
and
$625 um were represents the resolved
amount and that's for both those
resolves through the Attorney General's
office and the one at that point that
been resolved through the administrator
the report does give the breakdown of
those two numbers if you're interested
would you like me to give that just that
difference
so that report is forthcoming that
report is on our on our website and it
was provided
oh to the committee all right he's
yep so the report does give a
comparison because the resolved amount
is not necessarily going to be the claim
amount for some claims it will be um for
some claims it will be something less so
so to give you a picture of that the
comparison out of the 29 that were
resolved the claim amount was in excess
of 20
million but the resolved amount was 13
million so you can see that there's a
difference between and that's aggregate
numbers obviously so so that just gives
you a picture that claim amount does
always mean that that is the amount that
so the report also gives a
picture for those claims that have been
resolved what kinds of abuse was
resolved so of those 29 claims 17
involved resolution for both sexual
abuse and physical abuse
claims seven of them were sexual abuse
only claims and five of them were
claims the report also goes on to give a
picture of other ways that claims leave
the process some are withdrawn as an
example so at the end of quarter three
process um the report gives a dollar
amount that relates to those claims that
now were were they withdrew in order to
file to go to court or in order to just
negate the
claim um when when a claimant withdraws
from the process at that point the
administrator does not have a picture as
to whether they're going to continue to
pursue in court or not and some claims
if they withdraw it doesn't necessarily
mean that they have litigation pending
at the time so of all the claims that
are filed with us initially we do track
those that have related litigation
pending and therefore have to have a
stay put in the
court versus there are quite a few
claims that come into the process that
have no litigation pending at all so if
they withdraw if there's pending
litigation they can choose to pursue it
um if they don't have Penny litigation
they could bring it but that's not
something that the administrator's
office is involved
in I would just add I believe in both of
those cases the withdrawal happened
before um any decision had been made on
the claim so we don't know that they
withdrew because they were dissatisfied
they simply decided not to participate
anymore maybe they didn't
have a strong memory or maybe they
weren't able to provide do we ask them
to provide dates or anything that can be
verified dates of the claimed abuse yes
yes so the um claim packet itself when a
claim comes into the system um there are
dates that are and locations and kinds
of abuse that are um in the claim packet
itself it can be verified as to whether
that person and the other person they
claim abuse them were in fact present at
that site at that
time if the if the um claimant withdrew
their claim um it would depend on when
they withdrew it as to whether or not
that verification process actually
occurred um if it's an early on
withdrawal before the Attorney General's
office has done its
evaluation um then there really the
verification process wouldn't have
begun but if the claim proceeded to the
attorney general's position then I'll
let the Attorney General's office speak
for them elves as to what kind of
verification or what that would mean for
verification yeah than thank you for the
question representative um I I if I
understand what you're asking you're
wanting to be sure we're able based on
the information we're receiving from
claimants to at least verify that they
were at uh a state facility and that the
people that they claim to have abused
them were also working at that State
Facility um if that's the question then
I think the answer to that question is
yes in almost all cases we are able to
um either look through the facilities
records um or other we have other means
of looking at records to verify
employment there are occasionally cases
where we are not able to conclusively
establish um particularly the employment
because a claimant won't remember
someone's full name so we might get a
claim where they just say I don't
remember the CO's name but I remember
what they looked like right in those
cases we're not able to pull employment
records but to the extent that we have
the information we are looking at trying
to verify those kind of hard facts when
we get them thank you those are some
I've had in mind for a while to ask sure
members representative
leean thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my question not sure which
Jennifer I would direct this to but if I
recall we set aside aund million to
handle these claims and I see in your
report uh thus far it's about
175 million that the claims
filed is there sufficient funds with
that 100 million do you anticipate
settlement going over that hundred
million or the need to come back for
additional funding or is it too early to
ask that
question in some senses it's too early
to know uh the $171 million that you see
the report represents we just simply
totaled everything that had been asked
for through the end of quarter three the
actual awards are much less but I think
if you do the basic math of the number
of potential claimants that exist and
use the average price that we are
settling or the average uh uh award that
we are making um for claimants um it is
likely that the $100 million is not
going to be sufficient if we want to
resolve all of the claims through the
fund
chairman did you want continue
Q was oh continue what with Q4 numbers
well she can give me the numbers yes so
there there were further numbers to
come so we'll be Prov providing a report
every quarter um where almost through
with quarter four so that report will
come in mid January and if you um if you
are thinking in terms of um the cost uh
the for the state I can report just um
anecdotally that we're now uh in the
realm of having
resolved probably North of 60 claims um
for quarter 4 um and that the the amount
that will have been paid out of the fund
by the end of the the quarter I'm
estimating is going to be about twice
what it was at the end of quarter three
now as the payments that have been
structured so
far how many of them will go beyond the
end of this fiscal year this fiscal
bium would you say go beyond what I'm
I'm not sure what you mean so this this
B Anyan will go till um June of of
are some of these payments structured to
go beyond that date so the 100 million
is within this bium I see so if they go
beyond this
bium then we may be able to do a new
budget and a new a new
appropriation I understand thank you I
think it is likely that some payments
will go beyond the end of this bium the
date by which claimants have to apply
for compensation from the fund is the
end of the calendar year of 2024 so a
claim that came in in December of 2024
would work its way through the process
and potentially be resolved in the
second or third or even the fourth
quarter of 2025 so um assuming that the
process continues then I think that that
there would be um potentially uh some uh
Financial contributions in the next by
anym as well you have an estimate of
when the 100 million will be expended
will it be with within this
pum I do not we could look at that and
and let you know um as committee that's
information we need whether we need to
go look at other funds to transfer money
or whether we worry about the next
budget yeah I I think it would be
appropriate for us to address that for
you in the next quarterly
report thank you very much thank
you
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you do you have the numbers for Q4 to
date as you just went through them for
Q3 in terms of the uh total claims filed
and so on and so forth right down the
list
um do I all of those specific numbers I
do not we have I have a couple of
pictures that I could give you okay so
the couple of pictures I just went and
looked at our docket this morning um and
our um so from the present of where my
roet is updated because that takes time
in and of itself um we
notes the number of claims in quarter 4
as new claims that came in in quarter 4
is is north of
65 um so we have the rest of quarter
four to live and also I need to look at
my inbox to see how many more are
sitting there now um and then the other
number I took a look at just to give a
quick picture is the number of
resolution proceedings um um so we have
about again North is 60 Resolution
proceedings um that have been selected
by claimants that need to get uh some
are scheduled and happening and we have
um award or no award letters going out
um and some need to be scheduled um into
uh early
2024 um in order to go through the
resolution proceeding process with the
administrator
could you just clarify what you meant so
are I understand that you've made or the
U system has made offers to 60 claimants
and you're waiting to hear the what what
did that mean what you okay um
so I took a look at the numbers of how
many of the claims have selected a
resolution proceeding as the Avenue for
resolution and at this point we have a
little more than 60 claimants have asked
to have their claim resolved in front of
the administrator that number does not
represent the amount of award or no
award letters it's simply the pending
there is a portion of those that have
been resolved by the administrator and
that will be reported in the quarterly
report that shows how many and how much
including whether it's an award letter
or no award
letter
and and lastly when you when you before
I started asking these questions you
mentioned the I think this what you said
the resolve claims amount is now about
double what it was before so does that
mean around $26 million did you is that
what you stated yep I think that's
correct thank you very
much agree Mr chair at this time I since
quarter 4 report has not been done it's
not expect to be done until sometime in
January I would like to have an agenda
item either the January or the February
meeting so that we can discuss those uh
trying to do this off the cuff is I
don't think productive for us and uh
certainly I would like to see that
happen thank you yes we'll need some
written material in so that we can have
it included in
our I didn't even know it was on the
website
okay we will we will work on
that thank you y
further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you uh very much both of you for coming
in and and we'll see you again in
you okay we have a consent calendar that
covers U tabs three four five and six
and so far these are the um items that
have been removed from
23344 are there any further items
2336 and
right are there any further items to be
calendar seeing none move to consent
calendar as amended EXA a motion to
accept the consent calendar on tabs 34
five and six by Senator gray seconded by
Senator dallesandro further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppose
no the consent calendar with
the um subtractions I
listed is accepted moving on to the
regular calendar
tabs or first we'll move to the first
item
removed uh 23
364 that is the Department of Health and
Human
Services representative Earth is
recognized for questions oh thank you Mr
chair than take my questions so in a
question in response to one of the
responses that you provided um in
writing to your original
a note which related to the jsr the jrc
not being qualified and I'm my first
question is was it ever qualified to
receive funds in other words to any
process good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services I'm going to
have Chris selo speak to the the history
here a little bit good morning Chris S
associate commissioner um in
2016 um the department was in
discussions with CMS and at that point
in time um there was an understanding um
that certain situations could be covered
um at jrc and then later in about I
think it was um 2022 we were notified
that that was no longer the
interpretation further
questions okay so if I understand
correctly because also you indicated in
this thing that Not only was it against
the law for federal it was also against
state law as well at that point or at
some point yeah yes in
20 23 sorry I'm trying to go back in my
head um RSA
171a um there was there's a section of
it that says we have to comply with the
settings rule through CMS and that
actually came in effect in March 17th 20
23 right so based on that it sounds like
you were we the state was legally paying
for the services for a period of time
and then at some point in time it became
illegal to do that and then the Supreme
Court ruled that they ordered the
payment regardless and I'm just
wondering in that you didn't really go
into the ruling but in that ruling did
it State their reasons that they
basically said you have to make the
payments even though state law says you
don't have to make the payments we're in
AC of litigation on that um ruling right
now so that was a preliminary ruling so
we're still working through that but is
that ruling available that preliminary
ruling yes we can provide that to you
thank you that'd be
great that it for
me Senator alisandra thank you Mr
chairman first of all thanks very much
for for coming it it is a a little uh
convoluted here but we were a we were
ordered to pay court audited to pay so
and and our recourse is we are we are uh
questioning that at this point in time
and we're back in
court correct okay and and and uh who's
representing us the department or do we
have outside council department of
chair further questions from the
committee move the item sen Senator gray
moves the item Senator dallesandro
seconds it so even though they're still
in court this um vote authorizes them
900,000 if they need it if they don't
they won't but that's what they need the
authority to go forward everyone
understand the situation all in favor of
the of the uh request for FIS 23364 say
I I oppose no and that is adopted thank
you
and the next item removed
commissioner good morning for the record
Frank adbl Commissioner of Education
good morning and someone from the senate
had a question on this item thank you Mr
Senator dallesandro is recognized great
thank you thank you commissioner nice to
see you commissioner aren't you
occupying that space at the present time
yes so uh my question is what do you
need new furniture for if if you're
already occupying the space and you have
furniture from your previous location
that you could move over there yeah
thank you for the question I appreciate
that um so we are occupying that space
we have not been occupying the space
that we will be moving into um over the
past year Granite State College which
has now merged with University of New
Hampshire has been slowly moving out of
space uh several months ago they moved
out of some of the space that was
occupied um and so then we will be
moving our people into that space um
within the Granite State College the
furniture that they had there so for the
most part we've acquired all of the
Furnishings as well um but they had
certain areas that were more like Lounge
areas uh that were not necessarily
conducive to kind of a high density
office space so we allowed them to take
the lounge type furniture and we are
cubicles okay further question but but
we bought we're buying the building so
so are we allowing them to take the
equipment out of the out of the building
that we're purchasing mean we're paying
7 million do for that
building uh and and it seems to me a
we're paying 7 billion for it we're
buying it B we're already occupying it
and paying rent uh to uh the community
college system or whoever at at this
point in time and we're allowing them to
take furniture out of out of our
building so the price that we're paying
for the facility is
$6,750 th000 which includes all of the
Furnishing so about $7 million just to
be precise um and we have retained all
of the Furnishings that are usable uh
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that we have a uh a density that is
consistent with a normal corporate
environment as opposed to you know a
student lounge which is what this space
occupies and so we did need to acquire
some Furnishings for part of that
building I mean I can tell you even now
we don't occupy all of that building
there are three external tenants in that
building uh those tenants will be moved
out once the sale is closed and they get
a 90-day notification and they'll be
moving out and then we will be moving
spaces F further question F the question
so how many people do you have there now
and how many additional people will you
be moving over and where were those
people though so I don't have all of the
numbers in terms of the people in terms
of the exact count but right now I have
some people who are in Walker building
that will be moving over as we occupy
this
space thank you Mr
chairman further questions from
Committee
Member Senator gray move the item
second motion a second to adopt the item
is there any further discuss discuss
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor of adopting
23341 say I I oppose no
no how many NOS two do you wish to be
recorded yes sir
okay right the motion is adopted with
two
objections moving on to item
23344 Department of Business and
economic
affairs
another good morning good
morning you'll announce yourself oh
sorry Taylor Caswell commissioner
Department of Business and economic
Affairs and Chase Hegman director of um
economic development of
Bea I believe someone from the senate
had a question on this I believe that I
believe that the questions were coming
from uh senator berell who was not able
to be here today I think that uh
centered around uh how we decide which
people who go on trade missions are
funded through certain funds and how we
decide that people aren't being funded
um because she was uh one of the ones
who uh went on a trade Mission uh and U
that brought up the question so with
that as a lead in I'll turn it back over
to the commissioner it sounds like a
question who decides who gets funded and
who who does not get funded and do they
know this before they go well I I don't
know the specifics of this particular
request that was apparently made but as
it relates to that trip to Poland there
were two companies that were eligible to
receive funding under the federal step
program that we administer and those
companies did receive some funds uh to
alleviate the cost of of attending the
on the trade Mission there are questions
of
Eligibility uh that are directly related
to the program that we administer that
uh the individuals and the companies
that are paid are are that are eligible
for this are employers or staff that um
assist in that regard uh and represent
the state on our
behalf so I guess without specifics we
don't know know the answer it would be
hard for me to say specifically I do
know and because I in response to the
question that we received I did talk
with our staff and I I we we we are not
aware of any denial that we made to
anyone for that trip so uh if that's not
the case I would have to know more about
that further Senator gray um what would
be the consequences of uh tabling this
until the January meeting is there an
immediate need for the passage of this
or uh it's a great question Senator this
is funding for the next round of the
step program as it pertains to the trip
in question that was from the previous
round so this funding has nothing to do
with with that particular Mission and I
will just add for clarification sake
this funding is federal funding that has
specific requirements that the money has
to go to eligible businesses not um
indiv elected leaders or individuals in
the public it's specifically for
designated um staff um in the program
and the businesses that are eligible and
apply so they would in fact know ahead
of a trip whether they receive funding
for it because they submit an
application let me repeat the question
yeah okay what would be the effect of
postponing this until the January
meeting the effect would be uh any delay
in ongoing funding for this program the
step 10 program which is prior to the
Step 11 that we're seeking authorization
for now is a effectively out of funding
uh so any ongoing applications or
incoming applications over the next
month would likely be delayed if there
are any trade shows or exports or
related research that companies are
trying to engage in with this funding
there may be a delay for
them but we don't know of any at this
time that there would be a problem with
delaying this until January
meeting I can't specifically think of a
business that would be directly impacted
over the next month but I can certainly
check with our staff which is not
helpful in this particular moment um
other than to say we get regular
applications um in this until January Mr
chairman I do have a question before the
tabling motion if and I would be happy
before I accept the tabling motion uh
sen representative Lehman has a question
uh thank you Mr chairman and I would
certainly would second that motion after
my question but
uh there you mention in here out ofate
travel for like $8,600 and it says it
would enable between six and eight
people to participate that doesn't sound
like enough money to me to go to the UK
and put people up and the travel
expenses where did that figure of the
$8600 come from that's a great question
representative so the um 8600 came from
the initial application for the federal
funding itself and it relates to the
farm bur um trade show in the UK and
that will enable six to eight businesses
to be able to attend a booth that the
state would run so those costs are
related to travel and the booth costs as
well um and some funding for businesses
themselves to attend but that's a
percentage of their cost correct it's
not their not the entire cost correct
yesk thank you thank you Mr chairman
when you approve a business do you put a
limit on how many people they could take
the whole company or they could take
three or they could take two is there a
is there a limit on how many they can
take there's a limit on how much funding
they would receive so it depends on the
in um information in their application
so in the existing program the step 10
there is a limit per project or trip of
$6,500 and that that only covers up to
80% of the cost so the company has to
submit at least um or commit at least
20% of the cost to the trip
itself thank you Senator gray repeat my
motion to table to January
second motion a second to table further
dis and that's a non-debatable um motion
all in favor of tabling say I I oppose
no that is table until our next meeting
thank
you okay so now we
have dealt with all of the items on the
consent calendar we'll move to Tab S for
calendar and the first item
question no we did we did earlier thank
351 that is the Department of
safety Mr chair uh members of the
committee uh my name is Melanie ker I am
the new deputy director of
administration for Department of Safety
thank you would you turn off the other
mic no the other one just kidding turn
yours on thank you closer and move the
mic a little closer very soft spoken oh
got
it all right all right the uh division
of emergency services and Communications
has a request are there any questions
from the
committee
move the item okay a motion by
representative Lehman to move the item
second by Senator dallesandro to um to
accept and approve 23
351 seeing no further discussion you're
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no that is adopted thank you
very
23363 and that is Department of Natural
and cultural
resources this has been in the newspaper
lately because of an increase in the
fees which have hasn't been done since
2012 and we have here before us good
morning Sarah Stewart commissioner of
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources and with me I'm Brian Wilson
the director of the division of Parks
and
Recreation are there any questions from
the committee on the item increasing the
campgrounds obviously it hasn't been
done for quite some
time second Senator dallesandro moves to
approve Senator gray seconds is there
any further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppos
no you wish to be recorded Senor Shanley
is there any other knows that's the only
you did she say yes to yes yes all right
next item is on is on Tab 10 uh
correction on Tab nine I don't want to
skip anything tab nine 23 352 the
good morning Mr chairman for the record
Josh Elliot director of the division of
policy and programs with the Department
of
energy I'm Leonard Rdio the chief of
operations for the Department of energy
thank
you all right any questions from the
committee
members on the net metering always nice
to see Josh I'll tell you that good to
see you Senator Josh welcome to see you
thank you Senator move the distinguished
gentleman distinguished gentleman from
the Department of
En I'd second the I'll second the item
motion by Senator gray seconded by
Senator dallesandro to accept and
approve item 23
352 further discussion seeing none you
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no motion is adopted thank
you very much thank you very much Mr
chairman all right moving on to item
number 10 I'll
motion uh thank you Mr
chair
move to accept the office of legislative
budget assistance requests of for
approval to accept place on file and
release to the public in the usual
manner the following annual Financial
reports for the fiscal year ending June
30 2023 when they become available the
state of New Hampshire annual
comprehensive financial
report the New Hampshire dot Turnpike
system annual financial report the New
Hampshire Lottery Commission annual
comprehensive financial report and the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission annual
comprehensive financial report
further discussion seeing none ready for
the question is there a second to that
motion second by Senator Dallas
Sandro you ready for the question all in
favor say I I oppose no that motion is
adopted I believe we have an a request
assistant yes Mr chair on the top of the
next page we have item 366 with which is
a request uh for approval to fill two
Financial auditor
vacancies motion to two fill to fill two
Financial auditor vacancies at the LBA
audit
division second motion by Senator
alesandro second by representative F to
approve the
request you ready for the question all
in favor say I I oppose no that is
except accepted are there any other
questions on the informational material
committee all right seeing none we are
ready to
guess yes I believe uh the third Friday
in January would be the 19th
19th 19
o'clock any problem with the date or
time on January
19th seeing none all in favor say I I
oppose no that will be our next meeting
is there any further business to come
before
us night Mr chairman to wish everybody
on the of the committee a very merry
merry Christmas and a most happy and
prosperous New Year and and all of our
our audience who are hard workers for
state government uh thank you for your
service have a merry Christmas and I see
our Medicaid man here always nice to see
you here sir have have a great great day
Great American day and enjoy the new
year thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much and I think we all
Echo the same sentiments as Senator
dallesandro thank you all for coming and
thank you for all your good efforts
throughout the year and especially the
legislative budget assistant that always
keeps everything going
smoothly anything further move have
none you will move it I will move it
okay I move adjournment Mr move
adjournment Mr chair
okay motion to adjourn second by Senator
gray all in favor say I thank you all
very
much well not quite the fastest meeting
good